piano ferries has made 800 of its staff
redundant effective immediately and
cancelled all its services for the next
few days the company says it's acted to
secure its long-term future calls
today's decision very difficult but
necessary union bosses have described
the move as scandalous uh well we have a
statement from uh the company and it
says in its current state piano ferries
is not a viable business we've made a
hundred million pound uh loss year on
year which has been covered by our
parents dp world this is not sustainable
the statement went on to say as part of
the process we're starting today we're
providing 800 seafarers with immediate
severance notices and will be
compensating them for this lack of
advance notice with enhanced
compensation packages
uh a department of transport
spokesperson said uh the department of
transport is working with the kent
resilience forum and all its local
partners to ensure the free flow of
traffic in kent there are other
operators running services on
cross-channel routes so that passengers
and goods can continue to travel
ministers and officials that will be
speaking with piano ferries later today
to understand
more about those changes and the impact
on staff and passengers
well our business presenter ian king is
in the city let's go straight to him and
ian a complete shock for the employees
what sense is there that this was coming
down the pipeline
well this is a business that has been
struggling for a number of years it was
bought by dubai based dp world back in
2019 for 322 million pounds and it
hasn't made a penny profit since in fact
it's been loss making ever since dp
world acquired it it lost uh some 38
million pounds in 2019 in 2020 obviously
the year that the pandemic struck it
lost nearly 86 million pounds the 2021
results have yet to be published but you
read the statement there from piano
ferries in which it's reported it
admitted to a 100 million pound loss so
that's cumulative losses getting on for
250 million pounds over the last three
years i wouldn't say that all of this
businesses problems are down to the
pandemic although clearly that has been
pretty devastating in terms of what it's
meant for passenger travel over the last
two years there have been added
complications i think by the northern
ireland protocol uh obviously that
requires customs checks for uh in banned
uh traffic into northern ireland that
has clearly added to uh complications to
the business it owns apart from
obviously the well-known dover de calais
crossing piano also operates at ken ryan
to land crossing from scotland to
northern ireland across the irish he
also operates from
liverpool to dublin and from whole to
rotterdam as well but i suspect the
added complications of the northern line
of protocol have probably not helped and
we also know from recent cup from
previous company filings that there is a
significant liability owed to the
merchant navy uh seafarers pension fund
as well in the latest accounts to be
filed uh p and o recognized a liability
of some 146 million pounds and this was
of course a business that didn't receive
any support from the government during
the pandemic its appeals for support
were turned down and dp world the parent
company actually had to carry on making
loans to piano ferries to keep it afloat
during the pandemic those totals some 40
million pounds between the uh late 2020
and early 2021 it may be possible that
there have been subsequent loans made to
the company by its parent company since
then we don't know about those so
basically a business that has been
struggling for quite some period of time
worth pointing out as the business
points out in that statement that uh the
move the actions i'm taking today are
aimed at making this a sustainable
business long term there have been heavy
job losses already in recent years
shortly after the outset of the pandemic
p ferries made 1100 employees redundant
that at the time equated to around one
in four employees there have clearly
been other job losses since because
they're down now as a result of this
these 800 immediate redundancies today
to some 2 200 employees so this is a
much much smaller business than once it
was and clearly one that has been
struggling for a number of years now